and I think in a certain way that
Arjuna and withith actually spent a lot
of time
um interacting with each other in the
pre Olympiad training camp and since
then they spent they spent quite a bit
of time interacting which has the
pre-alumpia training camp the actual
Olympiad they were both in the India one
team so Arjun might have potentially
thought okay if I play the mainlands he
knows a lot of my repertoire I know a
lot of his as well but you never know
what he's been doing in the last two
months so what's the one variation I can
go for which no one takes seriously
and including with it and probably
that's what he went for the 1v3 line I
love how you put in the one variation
which no one takes uh seriously three
those were some shots fired by you uh
waiting for adivan's tweet on that but
uh completely agree with you that when
you've been teammates and when you know
each other's repertoire so well and
specially in this format you want to be
the first one to spring up a surprise